2023 cyber security predictions IBM data
fabric Solutions on AWS and the
introduction of IBM Cloud pack for data
Express all on this episode of IBM Tech
now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
as we Forge ahead into 2023 IBM security
X-Force and other leading experts
examine the cyber security trends of
2022 and looked at what we may see in
the year ahead
some of the predictions they made
include that ransomware attacks are
rebounding but not for all with the very
real possibility of a global recession
on the horizon experts expect to see
ransomware attacks Spike this year
however larger organizations in regions
heavily impacted during the ransomware
boom are the most prepared for this wave
after investing time and money in
fighting back
in line with a potential recession
opportunities for cyber crime as a
service May Skyrocket as hackers for
hire emerge in search of quick and easy
pay
this trend is facilitated by operators
offering new tools that dramatically
lower the barrier of entry for Less
experienced and less technical cyber
criminals
additionally it's likely that we'll see
more adversaries sidestepping new
security Technologies almost as fast as
the cyber security industry releases new
security tools cyber criminals evolve
their techniques to circumvent them this
year will be no different specifically
with adversaries setting their sites on
MFA and EDR Technologies
these are just a few of our experts
Trends and predictions for 2023 so make
sure you check out the blog in the
description of this video for a full
Rundown
next up let's take a look at some IBM
data fabric solutions that are now
available on AWS IBM data fabric
Solutions take the guesswork out of
deploying a data architecture that
simplifies self-service access and
consumption while addressing your
specific business problem
it can be a little tricky to determine
how to build up a data Fabric or figure
out exactly which components are
required to address your specific needs
that's why we're excited to provide the
following three data fabric Solutions on
AWS to address this problem
the first is data science and ml Ops
with IBM data fabric which unifies tools
processes and talent to build and
automate trustworthy AI models at scale
the second is multi-cloud data
integration with IBM data fabric which
makes trusted data available quickly in
hybrid multi-cloud environments and
connects the right data to the right
people for Accelerated innovation
and the third solution is data
governance and privacy with IBM data
fabric which creates a trusted business
ready data Foundation to automate the
enforcement of data protection policies
to learn more and get started with IBM
data fabric Solutions on AWS hit the
link below
for our final topic today we're going to
stick with the theme of data Fabric and
look at the forthcoming IBM Cloud pack
for data Express a set of three
pre-built pre-sized offerings designed
to address problems in cataloging
analyzing and integrating data the cloud
pack for data Express offerings give you
a choice of three popular data fabric
starting points IBM data governance
Express for a data catalog IBM elt push
down Express for data pipelines and IBM
data science and ml Express for
analytics and modeling
each provides pre-sized pre-selected
services designed to address a current
data fabric need and all three solutions
are built on the IBM Cloud pack
framework and the red hat openshift
container platform allowing them to be
deployed on premises or to hybrid Cloud
environments
full availability is planned for the end
of February so check out the link below
to learn more
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now